I think failing fast is important
experimentation is important and the
great breakthroughs in society usually
have required multiple tries multiple
experiments multiple pivots and that's
the whole idea of getting in there
getting some experience and then taking
a step back and figuring out how you
move forward the most classic case of
this was the whole idea that John F
Kennedy started about you know getting
somebody into space landing somebody on
the moon when he said that he called for
the country to rally around that it
almost was impossible for people to
imagine that happening but technology
just wasn't there but people tried
things many times failed this they
thought would work it didn't work they
kept adjusting kept at it and eventually
they were successful in landing somebody
on the moon and bringing them back home
safely so that's a perfect example of
many different experiments people see
this in science that they know that in
order to have a breakthrough in science
you have to try a lot of things most
things will fail and I remind people
Babe Ruth was the homerun King but he
also was the strikeout King if you're
swinging for the fences you're going to
strike out but you have to keep at it
and if you keep at it you know you
sometimes will have those home runs
sometimes you'll yell win those games so
I think it requires a mindset around
experimentation and taking risk knowing
that many things you try won't work but
that doesn't mean you're a failure that
just means that idea failed and what can
you learn from that idea and then move
forward sometimes you do have to call it
quits so sometimes things are just not
working but my own experience is
sometimes just when you think that
finally something breaks through and and
the sky opens up and there's new
possibilities we came very close to not
making with AOL there was many times
where it didn't quite work we thought
something would work it didn't we have
to lay people off we're about to run out
of money we had a partnership that fell
apart there were at some near-death
experiences on that road I used to joke
that Iowa was a ten year in the making
overnight success by the time it finally
got successful everybody said you came
out of nowhere no we didn't we were at
it for a decade and thankfully we didn't
give up we didn't quit we stuck with it
so sometimes you have to just say it's
not working you have to walk away but my
experience is if you really believed in
that idea early on you really were
passionate about that idea you still
think it could get traction for some
reason just hasn't broken through take a
fresh look at what partnerships you can
stay
that helped accelerate their growth what
new policies perhaps can put in being
put in place to accelerate the new group
don't don't give up on it now there's a
great Nelson Mandela quote it always
seems impossible until it happens